on est donc à Venise pour parler de Dali
d'accord alors peut-être petite question
typo pourquoi 5a et ce point
d'exclamation
c'est le nombre de de comédiens qui
jouent des incarnation voilà c'est bon
c'est une petite coquetterie parce que
il y avait il y avait le premier titre
le titre original c'était la plus grosse
caméra du monde voilà qui était un super
titre mais qui raconte un truc enfin
voilà c'est une fausse indication ça
aurait été une fausse piste en fait et
puis c'est chiant de dire au guichet je
veux voir bonjour deux tickets pour la
plus grosse caméra du monde voilà on
pense à ces trucs là alors justement
comment on choisit les les différents
interprètes qui vont dans la Somme va
finir par composer un avis alors moi
j'en ai convoqué au moins 10 voilà des
gens avec qui j'avais envie de
travailler des gens que je connais des
gens que j'avais envie de découvrir et
puis organiquement ceux qui en a plein
qui sont défilés en fait il est resté ne
sont restés que les plus courageux et
Édouard
sur
le département
j'en étais là puisque vous êtes vous
êtes si ça interpréter Daddy à quel
moment on garde telle ou tel Dali
pourquoi est-ce que par exemple c'est
Édouard qui ouvre avec cette scène du
couloir
[Rires]
ouvrir avec Edward c'était aussi parce
que tu es le plus disponible
j'ai besoin de temps
j'ai cru que le téléphone était pas
branché chez moi
et voilà vous jouez de une journaliste
en fait qui est incrusté
justement qui a le génie de la fausse
simplicité c'est le faux normal c'est la
folie déguisée en normalité justement
cette normalité que vous jouez au milieu
de cet univers totalement azimuté c'est
facile à tenir ça oui c'est facile à
tenir bah oui moi j'étais j'étais
vraiment en réponse à ces comédiens qui
proposaient toujours des choses
nouvelles et différentes j'avais du
plaisir comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
à jouer quelqu'un de normal et de simple
un personnage très simple avec Quentin
parce que c'était quelque chose de
nouveau pour moi puis voilà je savais
que le film sera un film de montage et
que ça allait beaucoup se créer aussi
après
qu'est-ce que vous faites là avec les
petits stylos
[Musique]
avec une caméra
cinématographique
les garçons sont en train d'essayer de
réparer la caméra et que vous avez fait
tomber par accident mais ça n'est pas un
problème outre mesure puisque les notes
que je suis en train de prendre dans ce
petit calepin vont me servir pour le
film évidemment après au poste
incroyable mais vrai fumé fait tousser
c'est donc votre quatrième film tous les
deux à quoi tient votre relation
artistique j'ai bien entendu dire que ça
dépassait la relation artistique puisque
vous parlez d'Anaïs comme d'une petite
sœur
je suis toujours très contente quand
Quentin m'envoie un scénario parce que
je sais que il va y avoir la promesse
d'un film très libre c'est un des
metteur en scène à part aujourd'hui qui
propose vraiment des choses extrêmement
créatives je sais pas moi je trouve que
c'est dialogues sont extrêmement bien
écrits c'est toujours un vrai travail
d'auteur et en même temps je sais qu'il
va y avoir beaucoup de recherches
formelles quoi qui va y avoir de
l'invention baudalie sont plus vrais que
nature on n'a jamais l'impression de de
d'un pastiche et d'ailleurs pour les
dialogues vous empruntez certaines
phrases au vrai Dali oui il y a dû
fermative là-dedans est-ce qu'au fond
Dali était pas un dialogue c'est génial
évidemment moi c'est ma fascination pour
Dali c'est avant tout son rapport aux
médias français
avant même sa peinture et et les
conneries qu'il est en train de
fabriquer à l'époque est-ce que comme
Dali Quentin va votre votre inconscient
vos rêves guides votre vie artistique
alors c'est pas les rêves c'est
l'inconscient effectivement c'est moi
cette façon d'écrire très simple qui
consiste à faire confiance
à l'inconscient c'est à dire que je
préfère une idée qui vient de nulle part
1000 fois plutôt qu'un truc réfléchi
mûrement réfléchi ou ou un truc un peu
fabriqué moi dès que ça dès que ça vient
de nulle part et que je le vibre là je
sais que je tiens un truc et c'est comme
ça que j'écris c'est je me laisse aller
j'ai trouvé la porte maintenant voilà
merci à vous deux super merci